A problem with adding more and more lights to a scene is the expense. Every
light you add means yet another light that must be evaluated for the surface.
One way around this is deferred rendering. Look at this demo. There are 50
lights in the scene, and it runs just fine. Normally, you render a surface, and
the fragment color for each pixel is stored, if it's the closest visible
object. This is often called forward rendering. In a deferred rendering
algorithm, you instead store data of some sort in each pixel. There are many
variations, with names such as deferred shading versus deferred lighting. And
here's just one. You could store the position, normal, and material color and
shininess of the closest surface at each pixel. You also draw into the Z-buffer
as usual. I'm not going to get into the details of how you store these various
pieces of data, the point is that you can do so. It's just image data in
another format. With deferred rendering every point light in the scene has an
upper limit as to how far its light goes. This distance forms a sphere. So a
sphere is drawn in a special way for each light. Another way of saying this is
that each light can affect a volume in space. Whatever surfaces we find inside
the sphere are affected by the light. Each light effects a fairly small number
of pixels on the screen, namely whatever area the light sphere covers. This
means that a huge number of lights with a limited radius can be evaluated in
this way. By drawing a sphere, we're telling the GPU which pixels on the screen
are covered by the light and so, should be evaluated. There are variants on
what shapes you draw. A circle, a screen aligned rectangle. Whatever is drawn,
the idea is that the geometry's purpose is to test only the limited set of
pixels potentially in range of the light. This is as opposed to standard
lights, where every light is evaluated for every surface at every pixel. I hope
this give you a flavor of how deferred rendering works. I'm really jumping the
gun, here. You need to know about shader programming to implement these. But
the idea is to treat lights as objects that are rendered into the scene after
all object surface values are recorded. There's some problem cases for
preferred rendering techniques, such as transparency, but it offers a way to
have an incredible number of lights in a scene.